[Music]
hello hi i'm mark and in this video
we're just going to be talking about
rainbows and
basically what i'm going to do is let me
just show you
rainbows it's rainbows
because who doesn't like rainbows
rainbows are commonly known as the
symbol of hope
peace pride the lbgtq flag
it's the symbol that god is never gonna
flood the earth again
and there may be a pot of gold at the
end of it so my entire goal for this
video is to fill this whole room up
with rainbows minus the gold coin i mean
that could be cool
and we're gonna try to do three pretty
simple experiments to try to accomplish
this
but before we jump into our experiments
i do want to understand and try to learn
how
rainbows are made how
are rainbows made
so i want to share with you the things
that i've learned and please correct me
if i'm ever wrong
and i'll try my best to keep it simple
when i'm talking about rainbows i'm
talking about the whole range of colors
visible to the human eye and this
rainbow is what
we see after that rain like what we see
in the sky
now sunlight we perceive as white but
it's actually the whole spectrum of
colors combined
[Music]
knowing this how can we take all the
colors from the light
and then spread them out make a rainbow
how does how does the rain do it well
whenever light passes through
materials such as glass or water like
rain refraction can occur meaning it
changes direction and speed and that
actually spreads
the wavelength of light when you spread
the wavelength of light you see
all the visible colors like the spectrum
and which is
rainbow i hope that all makes sense
and i just want to jump into our first
experiment because we're running out of
light
[Music]
so our first test or experiment is going
to be with a prism
let me show you my setup so i have i'm
just
reflecting light off of this glass so
that it can go through this prism
bounce off over here it's hard to see on
the phone
but it makes two rainbows right there
got our prisms right there hanging
and it's actually sending
rainbow all the way down here and just
for funsies
for later here's a little snippet of
what we're going to be doing
oh yeah here's another variant of the
prism
it's this thing and i believe these
crystals work
just kind of like a prism but it just
makes a lot more
rainbows tinier ones a little fun fact
back in the day they thought prisms
would color light kind of like a stained
glass
isaac noon actually proved this wrong
so the experiment that he did let me see
if i could recreate it i'm gonna go
close up
real quick uh here's a little quick
experiment to show you that
this is not staining the light you just
let one single color to go through the
slit
and the idea is like if you get another
prism and you put it on that color
if it colors the light it should be a
rainbow right
but no let's try a different color let's
try
blue blue green that's kind of cool
this shows that the prism is not
coloring the light but we're going to
keep moving on and let's go to our next
experiment
this looks cool next experiment involves
cds we just need a cd
you could already see the rainbows on it
and oh
i'm seeing some rainbow in the ceiling
but you probably can't see that where's
my rainbow
i'm seeing a little bit of rainbow i
don't know if oh wait can you see that
on camera right there
sort of similar to the prism the cd
spreads the colors of the light
and it's because of what's called
grading diffraction
sort of simple terms the cd has these
like
super micro gratings that are evenly
spaced out
and when the sun hits it and bounces
around
it's able to spread these colors
so if you bend it a little bit it kind
of combines all the color and makes it
more vivid i wonder if i could like
break this into little pieces and
actually make a disco ball with it
[Music]
won't break that's all i did to it
[Music]
let's move on for our next fact i want
to quickly talk about the colors of the
rainbow or
roygbiv why roy g biff and if you've
never heard of it
it's red orange yellow
green blue indigo violet i hope i got
that right
whenever you see a rainbow you'll notice
it's in this order
of roygbiv and why is that basically it
all comes down to
wavelengths and all the colors that
you're seeing
are the different wavelengths of that
light from red
having longer wavelengths meaning it has
lower energy
towards violet has higher energy or
shorter wavelengths
so and beyond that is something that our
eyes
can't see
it makes me think about like if you're
colorblind how do you see rainbows or
if you're an animal that can see like a
different range of spectrum
like what's that world like i digress
i just think light is so fascinating
that something
so simple that we see every day can get
so complex
but let's move on
so the sun has moved forward even more
and
this works perfect for our third
experiment which is my favorite
we just need water
wow no oh right over
so fill it up with water the only other
thing that we need
is a mirror the light bounces off the
mirror
and the water actually refracts it
so the water is the one that's slowing
down the light
and spreads it out so we could have a
rainbow there's
actually a specific angle that works
it's working whoa there it is
let me show you what's going on water
glass and you could actually see a
little bit of rainbow right there
reflecting all the way over there
it looks it looks dope i'm gonna touch
this
and then boom
it just it just comes to life
and they're just mesmerizing how they're
moving
the gradation is so smooth
i love it i love it
[Music]
with all this rainbow science what can
we actually do with it
besides appreciating its beauty well
we could actually use this to study the
universe which
is amazing to me and it's achieved with
something called
spectrus spectroscopy
it's where scientists use a device
called spectroscope
and this device can capture light from
space
and actually use the same idea that
we've been
doing with our experiments splitting our
light
and spreading the spectrum and this
rainbow spectrum actually contains
information that we can analyze and
figure out
what elements this light has interacted
with
so basically we're figuring out what's
out there in the universe by reading a
rainbow
anyways i basically want to use
everything that i've learned about
rainbows to create them
and then paint my room my apartment
with rainbows hopefully it'll work so
we'll see
as you can see if i'm dispersing that
[Music]
i'll just put some of the cds it's very
subtle
but it's there
[Music]
that's awesome
[Music]
i was this close to finishing it up
unfortunately
we ran out of time just no more sunlight
inside our room but there's always
tomorrow
so i'm gonna try again tomorrow
i've been running around trying to set
up this
rainbow because the light keeps shifting
and it keeps changing but i'm gonna
quickly show you
what i got all right
you ready for this
check that out that's so cool
it's like a party in here so i have
the crystals that my partner elizabeth
has and i combined them
i have a couple of prisms i have some
crazy contraption of all these
look at that the cd's actually doing
such a great job with that rainbow
look at all that all right what do you
think
whoa it's a party in here
whoa you can even like see it
oh that's so cool
[Music]
look at your crystals
whoa look at the walls
that's so cool i just wanted to see how
far i could
push it it's all fading slowly
i mean there's still some yeah but it's
kind of cool how it's
constantly changing yeah
overall i thought it was pretty
successful and it was
pretty amazing pretty magical i'd say
obviously the sun keeps moving so every
couple minutes
that rainbow would shift and change so i
have to switch all the mirrors and the
prisms
it was a lot of work but the results
were pretty amazing
i learned so much from our experiments
and i hope that you did too
i just think that it's so cool with like
something so simple we could
create something beautiful well
hopefully you liked the video as much as
i had fun making it
and that it inspires you to bring a
little bit of color in your space
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you